وانا احييكم فائدنا الى اخبار الساعه
نناقش فيها مجموعه من المواضيع وهذه
عناوين هذا المساء
فعلها اسود الاطلس وسجل سابقه عربيه في
تاريخ كاس العالم الاحتفالات وصلت الى
اسبانيا التي اخرجها المغرب من دور
الثمانيه
كف تفاجئ موسكو
وتربيقها بهجمه دقيقه في اقصى عمقها
الداخليه والغرب يعتبرها ضربه النفسيه تهز
روسيا
والاضراب يتسع في انحاء ايران والمحتاجون
يعتبرون قرارات النظام الاصلاحيه مراوغه
وتظليلا للالتفاف على الاحتجاجات
المبعوث الامريكي لليمنيتهم الحوثيين بعدم
الالتزام بالهدنه ويؤكد تلقيهم الدعم
والتمويل والتدريب من ايران
[موسيقى]
وانا احييكم مشاهدينا الى التفاصيل سيتذكر
العالم وعشاق كره القدم هذا اليوم جيدا
السادس مادسمبر عام 2022 حقق فيه المنتخب
المغربي انجازات تاريخيا وسابقا عربيه
بفوزه على اسبانيا في كاس العالم وبتاهله
لدور الثمانيه في مونديال قطر ليكون
المغرب اول منتخب عربي يتاهل لدور 8 في
مباريات في كاس العالم حقق المنتخب
المغربي وهذا الفوز التاريخي ركلات
الترجيح بعد تعادل سلبي خييما على الشوطين
الاول والثاني والشوطين الاضافيين
[تصفيق]
هذه الاحتفالات مشاهدينا وصلت الى اسبانيا
التي قطع عليها المغرب الطريق الى ربع
نهائي كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يوم تاريخيه بامتياز وانجاز كبير سنتابع
لاحتفالات من الرباط مع مراسل العربيه
عادل الزبير عادل اهلا بك معنا كيف هي
الصوره تبعناها في نشرات سابقه هناك
احتفالات ومن باريس
نعم ريم نحن معكم الان في تغطيه مباشره
ونحرك الكاميرا
نقترب اكثر من قلب شارع محمد الخامس
امامنا دقيقتين وسنكون في قلب شارع محمد
الخامس قلب الاحتفالات تسمعين اصوات
المنبهات هذه الفرحه المغربيه التاريخيه
قطعنا حوالي 10 كيلو مترات ماشي على
الاقدام للوصول الى قلب العاصمه المغربيه
الرباط يعني المغاربه خرجوا جميعا
الاحتفال نحن الان من قلب الاحتفالات
المغربيه
حتى تصل همم اين يحتفل المغاربه ولكن
سانتقل لي باريس مع فادي دهوك مراث في
العربيه فادي اهلا بك معنا كيف هي
الاحتفالات ارى الجماهير من حولك همم تفضل
لك الكلمه وصوره خاصه كافه تفاصيلها
[موسيقى]
لا عاملين كما ترين الجماهير ما زالت
تتواجد الى جهده الشانسي لزيف العاصمه
باريس منذ انتصار المغرب او انتهاء
المباراه الجماهير تقريبا في كل مكان
الطرق العاصمه الفرنسيه لكن هنا خصوصا في
مواجهه
المنتخب
[تصفيق]
اوه
كيف كيف ترى فوز المنتخب المغربي اليوم
الحمد لله احنا سعداء بالفوز تاع المغرب
وانت نتمناو يمشيو بعيد وتنسكروا اللعابه
اللي تقاتلوا كيفما تنقولوا في المغرب
بالدارجه المغربيه
وتنشكرون جمهور للساندهم طوله المقابله
وتنتمنى ان شاء الله يدوز لدمي فينال
ويفرحوا المغاربه ان شاء الله
وتنشكروه صاحب الجلاله يوفر كاع جميع
الظروف المغاربه
[تصفيق]
برتقاله وسويسرا اسهل المغرب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هل وصلت الى مكان تجمهر المغاربه وكيف هي
صوره عادل من عندك
عادل يبدو بان الاتصال من قطر مع زميلنا
عادل ازوبيلي ساعود لك فادي فادي انا
المواجهه القادمه ستكون فعلا كما ارادها
المغاربه او على الاقل من هو بجانبك مع
البرتغال توقعاته
[تصفيق]
نريد 2018
انت عشرتيني فيها روسيا صح
وكنت عنصر
اللاعبين
[تصفيق]
موجوده باعداد كبيره في الواقع في فرنسا
فكيف هي انطباعات الجاليه المغربيه ما
الذي رصدته وانت تتجول وتحضر لهذا المباشر
هل هناك احتفالات هل هناك تجمر في اماكن
اخرى من باريس تحديدا وفي عمره فرنسا هل
وردتك بعض المعلومات بخصوص ذلك
الاحتفالات تعوم معظم المدن الفرنسيه لكن
بشكل اساسي هنا في جده في العاصمه باريس
المغاربه يتجمعون هنا حتى في المباريات
السابقه في كل مباراه
كامله تجمعون هنا هناك انتشار امني كثيف
جدا للحفاظ على همم سلامه المشجعين الذين
تدفقوا بشكل هائل باعداد كبيره جدا الى
جداره ومن المتوقع ان تستمر الاحتفالات
حتى وقت متاخر من الليل مباراه الماضيه
استمروا للاحتفال في جده حتى الساعه
الواحده ما بعد منتصف الليل
[تصفيق]
فادي مبروك من جديد سنذهب الى الرباط
الكلمه
ريم مرحبا هذه العاصمه المغربيه الرباط
الجماهير تجمعت في قلب شارع محمد الخامس
قلب العاصمه المغربيه الرباط قلب وافراح
المغاربه في العاصمه المغربيه الرباط ليله
طويله بيضاء من الفرح من الجمهور المغربي
سنحاول ان نستمع لبعض الاراء ولكن اتمنى
ان ناخذ راي كي جاءك المنتخب المغربي
طيب يبدو بان الصوره توقفت على كل سنشكر
زميلنا عادل الزبير مراسل العربيه من
الرباط وشكر كذلك زمينا من باريس فادي
الدقوق مراسل العربي
مشاهدينا بعد هذا الفوز التاريخي للمغرب
الذي اسعد الجميع سيلتقي المنتخب المغربي
بالفائز من مباراه البرتغال وسويسرا التي
بدات والنتيجه حتى الان هدفان او ثلاثه
سجل البرتغال الهدف الثالث منذ قليل
للبرتغال مقابل صفر لسويسرا
سباق
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ها لدينا كذلك في اخبار الساعه
هكذا انتقمت روسيا التفاصيل بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
وانا احييكم مشاهدينا من جديد قواعد
اللعبه
على الاراضي الروسيه بل وضربتها في العمق
هذا ما كشفت عنه موت قله اعلانات عن تعرض
قاعدتين جويتين تقعان في عمق الروسي الى
هجمات
ثلاثه قتلى في صفوف الجيش الروسي ليكون
هذا الهجوم الاكثر جراه
وهو ما اكدته ايضا صحيفه التي ذكرت قبل
النوم اخرى
من الاراضي الاوكرانيه وذلك بمساعده
القوات الخاصه فما هي هذه التقنيه التي قد
تغير قواعد اللعبه في الحرب في اوكرانيا
الحديث هنا مشاهدينا عن مسيرات طورتها
اوكرانيا خصوصا لانجاز مهمات داخل العمق
الروسي فبحسب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه فان
هذه المسيارات التي سادفت المواقع الروسيه
هي سوفياتيه الصنع وهي ما يتماشى مع
الادوات التي تستخدمها اوكرانيا في تصنيع
الاسلحه ونقلا عن صحيفه
الاوكرانيه الجديده يبلغ مداها 1000 كيلو
متر ومن المرجح ان هذه المصيرات هي من صنع
شركه
للاسلحه المملوكه للدوله والتي كشفت في
مناسبه السابقه عن تطوير طائره بدون طياره
بعيده المدى
رغم تدفق الاسلحه عليها بشكل كبير الا ان
اوكران يختارت اذا تطويره بعض الاسلحه
بشكل فرسي لتحقيق اهدافها فالوصول الى
داخل روسيا لم يكن متاحا عبر الاسلحه
الغربيه سيما وان واشنطن ابرز المزودين
لاوكرانيا بالاسلحه ظلت تتجنب تقديم اسلحه
بعيده المديل اوكرانيا لتفادي مهاجمه
الاراضي الروسيه ربما لتبقي نافذه مفتوحه
على ساحه التفاوض
هذا هو ينعكس ايضا فيما كشفت او هذا ينعكس
ايضا فيما كشفت عنه صحيفه والسجون بان
الولايات المتحده عدلت سرار راجمه
الصواريخها مارس التي قدمتها اليوكرانيا
حتى لا يمكن استخدامها لاطلاق الصواريخ
بعيده المدى على روسيا وقالت الصحيفه ان
هذا الاجراء كان احترازيا من اداره بيضا
للحزيم المخاطر اندلاع حرب او ساعه موسكو
وفي سياق مرتبط يبدو ان الموقف الشعبي
الامريكي من دعم اوكرانيا بالاسلحه بدا
يشهد نوعا من التغيير حيث نشرت صحيفه وشك
واشنطوس استطلاعا للراي يظهر رفضا
لاستمراري دعم اوكرانيا بالاسلحه لاجل غير
مسمى واعرب ثلاثه ارباع المشاركين في هذا
الاستطلاع عن دعمهم لي فكره استقبال
اللاجئين اوكرانيين وفرض عقوبات على روسيا
فقط مع وقف الدعم العسكري مستقبلا وفي
الوقت الذي ما يزال فيه الدعوه الامريكي
لمساعدته اوكرانيا قويه
تراجع دعم الجمهوريه في هذا الصدد حيث
تراجع نسبه الجمهوريين المؤيده من 80% في
مارس الماضي الى 55% في نوفمبر
[موسيقى]
عموما المشاهدين
في كيفيه الحفاظ على سلامه
يستطيعون العمل داخل روسيا كما يحلو لهم
هذا هو عقد فورا او عقد الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين اجتماعا مع كبار مسؤولي
الامن الداخلي في روسيا لبحث الهجمات
لاوكرانيه الاخيره بطائره مسيره وذكر
لكريم لين ان بوتين عقد اجتماعا لمجلس
الامن مناقشه كيفيه ضمان الامن داخل
الدوله دون اعطاء تفاصيل اخرى عن الموضوع
كما قال الكريم لان هذه الهجمات وشكل خطرا
على البلاد
نفهم ما يحدث في روسيا او المنتظر على
الاقل مع زميلاتنا من موسكو مراسله
العربيه اهلا بك معنا اجتماعات امم على
مستوى عالي على خلفيه استهداف العمق
الروسي يقول البعض بان هذا تحول جوهري في
هذه المعركه هل تسربت بعض الامور يفهم
منها المنتظر على الاقل من جانب موسكو
مرحبا بك ريم بالفعل هي هجمات كانت ولليوم
الثاني على التوالي شهدتها روسيا من قبل
طائرات مسيره اوكرانيه كانت هاجمت يوم امس
مطارات عسكريه او تحوي طائرات عسكريه كانت
قد ادت الى مقتل ثلاثه جنود روس هذه
المسيارات قامت اختراق العنقه الروسي الى
الجانب الجنوب الشرقي لروسيا لي تهاجم
هذين المطارين في مدينتين مختلفتين هذا ما
شكل قلقا كبيرا للخبراء هنا والذين
اعتبروا انها اولا اختراقا كبيرا لنظام
الدفاع الجوي هنا في روسيا همم وبالتالي
كان هناك انعقاد لبجلس الامن الروسي اليوم
الذي اكد الكريم انه لا يتعلق بهذه
الهجمات هو عباره عن اجتماع دوري يعقدوا
مع اعضاء مجلس الامن الروسي ولكن هناك كما
تحدث لك ري- قالت كبير من هذه الهجمات
المتتاليه يوم امس واليوم التي اصابت
اهدافها استرات داخل العنقه الروسي في
روسيا طبعا كاتيا هناك بعض التسريبات تشير
الى انه مع تطور هذه الازمه ومع همم اتاحه
الفرصه امام اوكرانيا بالتحرك كما تحركت
اخيرا واستهدفت العمق الروسي هناك وكان
تحضيرات كذلك من جانب موسكو للبدء بمرحله
جديده في هذه الحرب لا نعلم ما مدى صحه
ودقه ما يصرب
حقيقه ريم كنا من همم من خلال القراءات
السابقه او من خلال ما حدث في وقت سابق
بعد استهداف شبه عفوا جسر همم جسر القرم
من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه كنا قد شهدنا
رده فعل كبيره من قبل اجانب الروسي بهامات
قد وجهت الى همم
مختلف قطاعات الاستراتيجيه الاوكرانيه
وقطاعات الطاقه ادت الى انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي هناك في اوكرانيا ولا تزال هذه
الاستهدافات مستمره من قبل الجانب الروسي
همم لاقطاعات الاوكرانيه لذلك قد يكون
هناك تصعيد ردا على هذه الضربات التي وجهت
مؤخرا الى همم مناطق استراتيجيه في العنق
الروسي على كل سنبقى في انتظار التطورات
لمتابعها شكرا جزيلا لك زميلات من موسكو
مراسيلته العربيه
كانتسامه شكرا شكرا
[موسيقى]
واقف المقابل المشاهدين هو امام الهجمات
الاوكرانيه التي تحدثنا عنها موجات
صاروخيه روسيه تتناوب على المدن
الاوكرانيه وتعطل سير الكهرباء والمياه
والتدفئه مدينه لذيذ هي اخر تلك المدن في
موجه ثانيه استهدفت محطات الكهرباء لتزيد
معاناه المدنيين بتزايد مستويات برد
الشتاء
لنور لا كهرباء ولا اشارات ضوئيه بعد
استهدافها بموجه جديده من الصواريخ
الروسيه اضطربت على اثرها محطات
الكهربائيه وتراكم الضغط على البنيه
التحتيه الحيويه فضلا عن انخفاض درجات
الحراره الى ما دون الصفر لتتضاعف معاناه
السكان بالتزامني مع حلول موسم الشتاء
القارس
لكن يمكنك بالتاكيد التكيف لدينا مصابيح
كهربائيه
طال جميع المناطق الاوكرانيه بعد ما تسبب
القصف الروسي بتطبيق نظام الاغلاق لتحقيق
الاستقرار في شبكه الامداد
موسكو حملت اوكرانيا مسؤوليه الاستهدافات
الروسيه للمواقع الاوكرانيه بعد ما نفذت
الاخرى هجمات بطائره مسيره تسببت في تفجير
قاعدتين جويتين ومقتل ثلاثه جنود
روسلانسكي خرج في رد على الروس ليقول
شعبنا لا يستسلموا ابدا مشيرا الى ان
بلاده اسقطت غالبيه الصواريخ الروسيه وبدا
المهندسون بالفعل العمل على اعاده
الكهرباء
نور يستحق السماء
لثواني الا وظلام يعقبه لايام صواريخ
الروسيه لا تزال تستهدف اوكرانيا وسط
التزايد المطالب الدوليه لايجاد حلول تحول
بين الخطوات العسكريه
والمدنيين امل الرويشد العربيه
[موسيقى]
السلطات الايرانيه لامتصاص غضب المتظاهرين
لم تشفي غليلهم بل زادتهم اصارا على
مواصله المسير المسيره عفوا الاضراب الذي
تم تدعوه اليه من قبل
بعض المجموعات وصل يومه الثانيه حيث اغلقت
عددا من المحل التجاريه والشركات اغلقت
ابوابها كما اضرب نحو 500 للعقود العامله
في شركات خزانات بيت روكيماويات في جنوب
غربي ايران كما تواصلت تظاهرات في عدد من
المدني الايرانيه لاسيه مع العاصمه طهران
ومحافظات خراسان وفارس ومشهد شمال شرقي
[موسيقى]
شيراز
والبنات وحشتيني
[موسيقى]
قالت الخارجيه الامريكيه انها لم تشهد ما
يدل على ان القياده الايرانيه تحسن طريقه
معاملاتها للنساء والفتيات او توقف العنف
الذي تتعامل به مع المتظاهرين السلميين
اما وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه فقط شجاعه
المحتجين معتبرا ان تقارير الغاء الشرطه
الاخلاق
بدور هذا كانت الخارجيه الالمانيه بان
المتظاهرين الايرانيين يريدون العيش بحريه
وبان الغاء شرطه الاخلاق في حاله تطبيق لن
يغير هذا الامر اطلاقا
التظاهرات تتواصل وسلطات الايرانيه ترد
تصعيد يفاجئ النظام الباحث عن مخرج ولو
بيكي نفسه
مجبرا ينظر النظام في امكانيه تخفيف بعض
القيود على النساء وفق ما ذاكرته صحيفه
اشارت الى ان مسؤولين ايرانيين بصدد وضع
اللمسات الاخيره على خطط لاصلاح انفاذ
القوانين المتعلقه بملابس النساء
كثيره مطروحه حول تلك التوجهات لا سيما في
مدى جديه النظام على التغيير والى اين
يمكن ان يذهب لا تفاصيل حول الاصلاحات
المزرعه غير انما رشح ياشي بتغليظ
الغرامات الماليه وتخفيف من الاحتجاز
والاستجواب
محاولات تبدو حظوظ نجاحها على الارض غير
مضمونه فالاحتجاجات مستمره والاضطرابات
تتوالى حتى ان القرار الاخير بحل شرطه
الاخلاق لم يكن كافيا ولا مقنعا
للمتظاهرين
توجههم مشكوك فيه خصوصا في ما يمس اسس
عقائديه يقوم عليها النظام اصلا وهو ما
بدا واضحا في كلام الرئيس الايراني اسس
الجمهوريه راسخه في الدستور اما المورونه
في وسائل تطبيقه كما يقول وهي وسائل لا
يثق بها المحتجون اساسا
هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا من عمان رئيس وحده
الدراسات الايرانيه في معهد الشرق الاوسط
للاعلام ودراسات سياسيه الدكتور نبيل
العتوم دكتور نبيل اهلا بك معنا النظام
الايراني اعطل دوريات الارشاد نتحدث عن
دوريه الاخلاق ودوريه الاداب كما تسمى
ولكن من جهه اخرى برلماني ايراني تحدث عن
امكانيه ان تعود هذه الصيغه ولكن بشكل اخر
هناك حتى حديث عن امكانيه اغلاق حسابات
بنكيه لمن لا يلتزم بقواعد اللباس او
قواعد الارشاد عموما ما الذي يريده النظام
مساء الخير ستريم ما يريد النظام هو قمح
هذه التظاهرات واجبار المحتجين للعوده الى
منازلهم كما تعلمين ريم الان النظام
يتجاهل اسباب هذه الاحتجاجات هو يحاول ان
يمارس سياسه قمعيه غير مسبوقه عبر سياسه
الاعتقالات سياسه تنفيذ الاعدامات وايضا
السياسات العقوبات الماليه على المضربين
او على المحتجين وغير ذلك وحرمانهم حتى من
الوظائف العامه صحيح انه تم الاعلان عن
همم
هل ما يسمى بشرطه الاخلاق لكن هنالك اجهزه
امنيه معنيه بمتابعه ما يسمى بقضايا
الحجاب والالتزام
بالاعراف والتقاليد الاسلاميه كان سابقا
لما كنا نعيش في ايران كان هناك ما يسمى
بالكوميتيه وهي لجنه خاصه بمتابعه ما يسمى
بشؤون الحجاب في الاماكن العامه ثم ترن
تغيير الاسم لكن هنالكريم
اساسات امنيه اخرى يعني قوات البسيج
زينبون او زينبيات هذه الفرقه التابعه
لقوات الباسيج ايضا هي بمراقبه همم
الاداء العام للسكان وحتى المارين في
الشوارع وفي الاماكن العامه النظام
الايراني يرى بانه بهذه الاجراءات هو كما
يقول يثبت سلوكا اجتماعيا همم
كيف سيؤثر ذلك على الاحتجاجات اولا همم
وما يقدمه هو او ما يروج له بانه خطوات
اصليه هل ستقنع
طبعا لن تقنع الشارع بدليل انه يعني
الشارع ولا يتحدث فقط عن قضايا ال ال ال
الحجاب وقضايا حتى الحريات ويتحدث عن
تغيير سياسات النظام يطالب بها اعاده
هيكله النظام لطالب بتغيير وليس تعديل
الدستور الايراني وهي اجراءات تحدث عنها
عدد من المسؤولين الايراني في مقدمه محمد
باقر قريبا في رئيس مجلس الشورى الايراني
تحدث بشكل واضح وصريح ثم تراجع عن حديثه
وتحدث عن ان النظام مستعد لعمليه الاصلاح
لكن اولا شرط الامن اولا ثم الاصلاح ثانيا
وببدا يطرح عديده همم تتعلق باعطاء سقف من
الحريات وايضا التوسل بسياسه جديده
عنوانها صراع المصنع داخل التيار المحافظ
عبر تقسيم هذا التيار الى تيار اداري تيار
الصمود الذي يدفع الى ابراهيم رئيسي وتيار
اخره وتيار اصلاح تجديد من رحم التيار
المحافظ وارد عليه حتى الشعب الايراني ورد
عليه عدد من 600 من الاكاديمي في كانت
هنالك عريضه تم تقديمها الى مجلس الشورى
الايراني طلب باصلاحات حقيقيه وقالوا ان
هذه الاصلاحات هي اصلاحات مزيفه بهدف خداع
الشارع الايراني
سيبقى موضوع للمتابعه ساكتفي معك بهذا
القدر على ان نعود لن نناقش مختلف تطورات
ولكن لاحقا من عمان رئيس وحده الدراسات
الايرانيه في معهد الشرق الاوسط للاعلام
ودراسات السياسيه الدكتور نبيل العتوم
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
والى موضوع اخر الان حيث هو حمل المبعوث
الامريكي الى اليمن
الحوثيين مسؤوليه تدهور الاوضاع الانسانيه
في اليمن مؤكدا في جلسه في الكونغرس
الامريكي حول اليمن ان الايرانيين يقدمون
التمويل والتدريب والاستشارات العسكريه
للحوثيين
داخل اليمن
الايراني يجب ان يغادر اليمن ما هي
الاعداد عدد الايراني الذين يتحدث عنهم
بالعشرات
ولكن ما يكفينا يكون لهم الاثار واللتوفير
النصح للحوثيين من صعب القول كنا نعتقد
يحصل على فائده كبيره جدا من كل القتال
الدائره في اليمن
المكونات
والتدريب اليمنيين او للحوثيين بشكل كبير
[موسيقى]
مشاهده مسلسل
الى اجواء الاحتفالات بفوز المنتخب
المغربي اليوم نتابع جانب من هذه
الاحتفالات من الدوحه حيث
يجرى كاس العالم ومن هناك معنى ليس بازاري
لايف اهلا بك معنا الاحتفالات متواصله
وربما ستواصل الى ساعات صباح الاولى
معك في هذه الصور الكلمه لك ليك تفضل
جيبوها يا لولاد
اليوم مغاربه فوزي المغاربه هو وفوز العرب
هذا ما يقول الجمهورنا وكذلك نشاهد
الاحتفالات والاغاني الرائعه والاغاني الي
الي الي اسود
[تصفيق]
مغربيه مغربيه
اليوم كان رجال اليوم كانوا رجال والحمد
لله والشكر لله واضرب لكم
مغربي
والله يا اخويا
شقينا في المدرب وهو ورينا التيقه دياله
يعني كيفيه تعطينا الثقه وكيفاش نردد لنا
الثقه دياله ان شاء الله طامحين بس يكون
عندك جمهور بهذا الكيفيه ولعابه كبرت
تبارك الله ان شاء الله في الفينا ان شاء
الله وعلى شنو انتم والمونديال وتحيه
الجميع همم
علينا برافو الرجال
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في المباراه
[تصفيق]
شرفنا المنتخب
اصغر
مشجعه ولكن قويه بترجيحه لايت لو نختم معك
باختصار شديد بالاغنيه التي كانوا يغنيها
منذ قليل من من التقاليد المغربيه همم
كانوا منذ قليل يهتفون ويغنون بالاحرى
اغنيه من بين تقاليد المغربيه لو يعيدها
فقط لنختم
[تصفيق]
ههه
سيبقى واقفا طول الليل انا متاكد المغايب
عندما يفوزون المباراه وهو شيء اخر هنا
سوف
اكتفي معك بهذا القدر اسمح لي ولكن اكيد
باننا سنبقى في متابعه هذه الصور ولكن
لاحقا اود شكرا جزيل الشكر استمتع لايف
كذلك بالفوز لاني اعلم بانك فرحت وسعت جدا
بهذا الفوز شكرا جزيلا لك ليس بازاري من
الدوحه
مشاهدينا عموما سنعود المزيد حول مباريات
كاس العالم بعد الفاصل في موجز رياضي
ولكن لدينا في اخبار الساعه ملفات
السياسيه الى الماسك يثير الجدل ليس من
العصفور الازرق هذه المره
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد بحث وزير
الخارجيه الاردني
الملك عبد الله الثاني ورئيس الوزراء
العراقي محمد شايع السوداني في عمان الشهر
الماضي واكد الوزيراننا البلددين بتوسعه
التعاون في مختلف المجالات وفي جهود
مكافحه الارهاب
وتكريس الامن والاستقرار وتعزيز التنسيق
اذا القضايا العربيه والاقليميه
[موسيقى]
هبدا وزير الخارجيه التركيه مولود شاويش
او قلوب
اذا وصلت تسريحه جذورها في بحر ايجار
وقالت شاويش اوغلو انما وصفه بالانتهاك
المستمر للمعاهدات سيفتح سياده هذه الجزر
للنقاش وسيجبر تركيا على الدفاع عن حقوقها
مشيرا الى انها يجب ان تظل منزوعه السلاح
بما يتماشى مع المعاهدات الدوليه
[موسيقى]
انقلعت الشبكات حاده بين النواب داخل
البرلمان التركيه مع مناقشه الميزانيه
العامه لعام 2023
ووفقا لتقاريرات تركيه اشتبكا نواب من حزب
العداله والتنميه مع نائب من حزب الخير
وقد تم نقله بسبب اصابته عبر الاسعاف الى
المستشفى
[موسيقى]
ذكر مسؤول في حكومه طالبان انه يسمح
للفتيات الافغانيات باجراء امتحانات
التخرج من المدارس الثانويه بالرغم من
منعهم من فصول الدراسه منذ سيطره طالبان
على البلاد ووفقا لوثيقتين من وزاره
التعليم طالبان يطبق القرار على 31 ولا
يتنف غنيه من اصل 34 قبل بدء عطله الدراسه
الشتويه اواخر ديسمبر
[موسيقى]
متابعه مختلف ملفاتنا في اخبار الساعه حيث
تواجه شركه نيوروليك للاجهزه الطبيه التي
يملكها الملياردير الامريكي الى الماس
تواجه تحقيقا نتحازيا في ما زعم بنتها
كانت المحتمله لحقوق الحيوانات تاتي وسط
شكاوى من وظائفين بشركه من تسريع التجارب
على الحيوانات مما يتسبب في نفق الكثير
منها وفقا لوثائق طلعت عليها رويترز وكذلك
لمصادر مطالعه على التحقيق
وعمتيات الشركه
[موسيقى]
نهايه اخبار الساعه عليها هذا اليوم في
الختام تفكيره بيبرز العناوين
فعلها اسود الاطلس وسجلوا سابقه عربيه في
تاريخ كاس العالم الاحتفالات وصلت الى
اسبانيا التي اخرجها المغرب من دور
الثمانيه
كيف تفاجئ موسكو وتربكه هذه هجمات دقيقه
في اقصى عمقها الداخليه والغرب يعتبرها
ضربه نفسيه تنسى تهث روسيا
الاضراب يتسع في انحاء ايران والمحتاجون
يعتبرون قرارات النظام الاصلاحيه مراوغه
للالتفاف على الاحتجاجات
والمدعوف الامريكي لليمنيتهم الحوثيين
بعدم الالتزامه بالهدى ويؤكد تلقيهم
الدعوه والتمويل والتدريب من ايران
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]